[Music]
about it
maybe you notice this isn't like a
regular concept
the show is about our history as
Americans that history is in our songs
[Music]
I knew I wanted to do the whole show as
a 24-hour performance but I only wanted
to do it once
tonight
and tomorrow it's a 24-hour performance
that asks us to practice joy and
exuberance and maximalism my God totally
inspired I was like oh my God I get to
make 24 historical like period costumes
okay
part of the art was that the audience
would be with us for 24 hours as well
[Music]
Taylor's created something that is a
radical format Gloria Gloria
[Music]
[Applause]
the audience they start to support us
more we lose energy on stage but they
give more energy
[Music]
the people I'm interested in what
happens when the audience has to make a
commitment to something that stops being
just a party game it becomes something
deeper
the reason we have problems is lack of
community when all
the artists the artist's job is to dream
the culture forward and you're alone
to look at the things that aren't
working in society and imagine how it
could be better
you can lie
ultimately for me it's all about
experiencing the full range of who you
are and taking the time to actually do
that
everybody